معنا من عمان لواء فايز دويريا الخبير
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بيك كل
عام وانتم بخير هذا الاختلاف في التكتيكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع ما تاثيره عمليا
على الارض
يعني هي دعنا نقول يطلق عليها الحرب غير
المتناظره او الحرب غير التقليديه
وبالتالي على الجيش السوداني ان يطور من
اداء العمليات ومن المقاربه المتبع لانه
لا يمكن يعني لا هي تقع بين حرب المدن
والحرب
الهجينه لماذا لانها لا تقاتل بطريقه حرب
المدن المعروفه تاريخيا يعني لا يمكن ان
نقارن ما يجري في الخرطوم بما جرى في
الموصل وطريقه قتال داعش
والاستعدادها لان تقاتل من بيت الى بيت لا
الان هذه تقاتل باليات دفع رباعي تتحرك من
شارع الى شارع من نقطه الى نقطه وبالتالي
هي عمليات كرو وفر اكثر منها عمليات معارك
صداميه هذا يفرض على الجيش السوداني
من اداءه الميداني بالدفع باليات
متوسطه وليست ثقيله حتى يكون لديها قابليه
حركه ويكون لديها سرعه رد الفعل ولكن
احيانا حضره اللواء احيانا الجيش السوداني
يستعمل الطائرات هل هذا ذو جدوى
هذا هذا ما كنت
ساكمل الحديث في هذا النقطه ان بما ان هذا
هو الواقع قابليه حركه متميزه لاليات دفع
رباعي خفيفه تقوم بعمليات مباغته وهجوم
وانكفاء وتخفي وبالتالي
الاليه التقليديه لاداره المعركه من قبل
جيش نظامي باعتماد اليات ثقيله هذه لن
تجدي نفعا لماذا لا يمكن اعاده تجاوزها
وتغطيها بمعنى اخر قد تتقدم هذه الاليات
ولكن تندفع اليات الدفع الرباعي من شوارع
فرعيه الى مناطق خلفيه اذا لاحظ الجيش
استخدم كلمه تمشيط اي بمعنى اخر تطهير
كامل هنا عليه ان كما قلت يوظف اليات
متوسطه واليات خفيفه اكثر منها اليات
ثقيله عليه عن
يزيد من
اعتماده على الطائرات وخاصه الطائرات
العموديه وليس الطائرات الطائرات المجنحه
قد تستخدم على اهداف الرئيسيه لماذا لا
نحجم القنابل قد تصل الى 500 باوند هنا
عليه ان يوظف ويستخدم طائرات ميل 24 وهي
ما يطلق عليه الدبابات او قانص المركبات
هذه قد يكون لها دورا فاعلا في تطوير
عملياته لكسب الوقت من اجل تحقيق انجازات
والا ستكون مضنيه مكلفه ماديا وزمنيه شكرا
لك لو فائزه من عمان